you think you've just cooked an
authentic paella but be careful because
as the towel goes
it was once said if you were to put the
wrong ingredients in a traditional
paella like avocado or chorizo then he
would appear
who is he
he is the online guardian of all
traditional paellas
the wiki
paella
[Music]
an online platform dedicated to keeping
the paella dish true to its valencian
roots
[Music]
[Music]
and that was certainly the case in 2013.
paella fouls were being committed
everywhere the use of trees at
restaurants was through the roof and i
mean some people thought rice was
optional
come on
so to defend the integrity of the dish
our man here got two friends and
together they looked for the legitimate
ingredients
has
[Music]
if you're wondering if you can use
seafood yes you can but there's some
rules
[Music]
these two ingredients were then shared
around the world on their website
wikipedia for restaurants and home cooks
to study but this mission was much more
than just fixing paellas it was also
about celebrating those restaurants that
got it right
the platform's already okay 350
restaurants and cultivated a global
community of up to a thousand people i
mean it's even helped redesign the payer
emoji remember no meat and fish together
and no peas comprende
that's much better
so
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you